hello our welcome to Playstation grenade
it's time for our regular meet up once
again to go through the story of
fortnight Battle Royale we haven't done
this since season seven so there's quite
a lot to get through Botnick battle
royale has an ever evolving storyline
which seems quite random at times but as
each season brings new live events we
are slowly piecing together law let's
not mess around chatting we've got tons
to get through so sit back relax use
code Adam are you in the fortnight's
shop and let's go through fortnight
battle royale the story so far the first
live event which shook the in-game world
started off as a shooting star across
the skies during season 3 but as the
days turned into weeks that burning
fireball in the sky looked like more
than a passing comet lookout points and
viewing platforms were constructed
around the island welcoming the meteor
we all tried and failed to predict the
day it would hit us and some even
predicted alien life to be unbarred that
UFO suddenly without warning pieces of
the comet began to hit the island
destroying man-made structures
influencing fights and causing havoc
everywhere
with the introduction of season four
fortnight's island was finally hit by
more than debris large portions of the
former UFO destroyed many areas of the
map with the main impact destroying
dusty depot and turning it into a barren
hole in the ground instantaneously the
government erected barriers around the
impact site hiding away the central part
of the meteor those remains glowed red
potentially indicating life inside
elsewhere around the islands the cleanup
began with government officials
transporting the fragments of the comet
some of which granted anti-gravity
abilities momentarily to anyone who
touched them tilted towers narrowly
avoided complete annihilation but one
building wasn't so lucky that building
and all the other areas were renovated
over the following weeks and months
finally it looked like all the fragments
and hot rocks were being transported to
a mountain over by snobby shores the
mountain was revealed to be a lair cut
into the rock face hidden from the
majority of the island some say it was
created for a movie shoot others
believed this was a facade and a secret
government facility is housed inside
especially as a rocket was seen either
way everything was about to change after
the final meteor fragment over by the
crater was discovered opened and whoever
was inside left a trail of destruction
all the way to the mountain lair the
visitor was revealed but nothing is
known about his origins he quickly found
a way to power the rocket and then came
the day he chose to launch broadcasting
the signal to all the televisions in the
vicinity either warning the innocent of
preparing them for annihilation was he
here to conquer us or was he simply
trying to get back home what happened
next
only happened a single time and could
not be repeated here's how it went down
the visitor somehow managed to create
ruptures in time and rifts between
dimensions although it looked like
tilted towers was about to be destroyed
a malfunction caused the rocket to warp
around the map the rift left behind
began to eat away at the four night
world with nom noms the tomato head and
the derp burger being ripped from this
reality and vanishing overnight but then
something even stranger happened items
from other worlds began to drop through
the rifts in time a stagecoach was found
above moisty mayor and a huge anchor was
spotted between snobby shores and greasy
Grove which look ancient in design
perhaps Roman perhaps knows something
was definitely happening here season 5
arrived and changed the world further
once the rifts in time and space opened
the drift character was dragged onto the
island alongside the fabled der burger
midway through season five the crack in
the sky began to burn down a group of
cactuses cacti cactus cacti whichever is
correct once all the cacti were
demolished the rift did this
a mysterious cube was created which
gifted shield when close enough but
would repel any damage at the closest
player to the cube so what did we all do
we all killed each other for a while
which was fun
eventually the cube began to roll around
the map and left Nordic runes in the
ground linking back to the norstein we
found in the battle paths and the theory
of Ragnarok bringing the end to the
current world over the next month the
cube went about its business including
smashing down the building and tilted
towers which has been under construction
since season four began epic just love
to trollers back to the loading screens
saw the arrival of the enforcers which
look like intergalactic police we'll
have to wait to see what happens here
because even on the last day of season 5
nothing has been confirmed watch this
space so the cube finally made it over
to loot Lake and this happened
[Music]
the cube melted into loot lake causing
the top layer to become a repellant kind
of trampoline gel loot lake became
Thanos Lake or at least that's what the
community called it one week later
things changed yet again season six
began and the cube was not finished with
us yet
lifting the loot lake island into the
air
[Music]
the moment the floating island was
created the cube took it for a ride and
revisited all the rune spots on the
island ripping them out of the ground
and transferring some sort of energy to
them before moving on to the next over
two weeks the cube island moved around
the map slowly expanding itself through
the house above once the cube reached
the final room another phenomenon
happened all the surrounding rooms were
ripped from the ground and pulled
towards the cube this time the cube was
feeding from all the rooms and over the
next few days the cube reached its full
capacity
the floating rooms dropped from the sky
and hit the ground and the cube island
went back to its home above loot lake
with its newfound energy the cube
projected a beam of light into the air
and fought nightmares began
the island became infested with the
undead these husks were everywhere the
loot lake island was smashed into pieces
but with his job done the cube began to
drain away the energy and power it had
built up for the season opened a gateway
to a zombie Cataclysm for five days we
battled against the husks the nightmare
was almost over and to mark the end
another live event brought chapter one
to a close the end of the cube
rest in peace Kevin is how it went down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
once Kevin the cube left us replacing
loot lake with leaky lake
we thought this must be the end but as
the rainbow dulled the cold winter air
kicked in and the next episode in the
saga began
down by flush factory a mysterious
parachute was discovered with the
questionable logo which could link to
the satellite surveillance found in save
the world but this wasn't our major
concern because out in the distance was
a cloud of snow quickly moving towards
the island winter is coming
suddenly aim was uncovered wearing the
exact same logo and subtly hiding in the
background of our games watching us
waiting and reporting back to someone or
something as season 7 began a huge
change to the island was witnessed the
cloud of snow hid an iceberg which hit
the island changing the entire lower
left 3rd filling it with snow and icy
weather life went on with the destroyed
building in tilted towers once again
resurrected but for how long this time
the iceberg brought explorers to the
island who set up outposts across the
isle finally telling us who sent aim in
season 6 but this was only the beginning
as the iceberg slowly melted away
revealing a medieval castle underneath
for weeks we watched it thaw uncovering
a throne room and a dungeon below with
death traps tools of torture and sacred
dragon eggs something was going to
happen here a sword of immeasurable
power showed us the icebergs mysterious
potential and turned brother against
brother until it was once again locked
away under ice we had a taste of godlike
power for a while the island was
peaceful again we collectively stopped
and saw in the new year together but far
more was yet to come TV screens around
the island sprang into life again
warning of negative temperatures and
then it happened above the castle a
sphere as depicted in the Explorers
emblem appeared inside the ice ball was
the Ice King waking from his slumber
gaining strength and summoning mythical
energy and does that look a little bit
like Kevin just a little bit the
televisions once again counted down the
moments until the next live event began
the Ice King awakened
[Music]
deep under the frozen castle something
was happening a captive was slowly
Thorin out of his icy prison his skin
was like volcanic rock over the next few
weeks the prisoner began to evolve first
removing his shackles before gaining
volcanic powers by the end of season
seven
he had become a molten God to rival the
Ice King setting up home in wailing
woods smoke and ash began to rise
suddenly something happened to change
the very shape of the Battle Royale
Island a volcano sprang up indicating
the start of season 8 the changing
landscape also attracted nearby pirates
who set up their home in lazy lagoon
this led to a three-way battle for
supremacy ice versus fire versus those
pesky pirates - as season a continued
the men in black those secret government
officials began to look for something
under the islands surface dig site
sprung up overnight and finally they
found it it was there under loot Lake
the place where Kevin walked to all
those seasons ago had a secret beneath a
vault futuristic in design as time went
on the inhabitants completed tasks to
open the vault and finally the day came
the vault opened and here's what
happened
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow a lot to take in there first the
community voted to bring back the drum
gun back in the present day both retail
row and tilted towers were destroyed and
remember that building which was
constantly destroyed well that was the
one and only building to live through
the volcano events well played indeed
epic games during the event Jonesy and a
human-sized banana yes that's a real
thing in fortnight Battle Royale made
their way to a hidden bunker to provide
cover whilst the volcano blasts
continued they became trapped inside for
so long that Jonesy ate his fruity gem
until the future arrived
[Music]
set free in a new world rebuilt after
the volcano event a new tilted towers
rose up neo tilted and retail role was
replaced with a mega more the helm from
the vault can now be seen in neo tilted
but one more thing happened to confuse
us further one of the volcano blasts
cracked the ice cap at polar peak only
now has something changed in the ice
another being can be seen a potentially
huge being is this the all-seeing eye or
is this some sort of godzilla-sized
behemoth behind that sheet of ice what
will happen next at this point we don't
know looking at the fort by ton
lockscreen johnsy has linked together
Kevin the cube and that all-seeing eye
at polar peak can you predict the next
story beat in this saga I'll be in the
comments to find out and there we have
it we're up to date thanks for watching
if you'd like to support me please use
code a damaru in the fort night shop and
I will continue to make these videos
thank you to everyone who has supported
me you make a real difference to the
videos that I make I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]